and lastly foreign secretary Winter
Olympics just around the corner of
course so due to open in Sochi next
month and I remember last year the Prime
Minister raising the issue with
President Putin at the g20 of the
anti-gay laws that the Russians have
bought in now the Americans seem to be
sending three openly gay athletes and
former athletes in their delegation
what's UK going to do about that well
this is a point that we have made very
strongly as you say the Prime Minister
has raised it we've raised it at many
levels there's no doubt in Russia at all
about what we think about these matters
and will be very clear about that
throughout was making the decisions
about our delegations to Sachi but
there's no doubt whatsoever in the minds
of the Russians how strongly the United
Kingdom stands up for LGBT rights and we
will continue to make that very clear
well it would be helpful like the
Americans to send someone who's openly
gay wouldn't it well let's all this will
become clear over the next few weeks
watch this space